other breaking news this morning
happening right now in fact the downtown
area metro police are investigating a
murder this is in the area first in palm
lane and that is where bianca holman
joins us live to explain exactly what's
been going on this morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning
heather so here at palm and biltmore
there was actually a red vehicle in
front of a yellow house right here that
was has been towed and this is also
where officers were taking a lot of
picture gathering a lot of evidence but
this is not the only area where they've
been all morning they've been right down
here at palm and first and you can still
see a police cruiser down there and
yellow tape up so a large perimeter of
an area where they're investigating a
homicide and this to give you some
perspective is just east of main street
so this is a downtown las vegas
neighborhood in these early morning
hours as police are investigating a
murder so as we learn more details we
will keep everyone updated but as of
right now you can still see that police
are actively still gathering evidence
for the situation that happened
overnight just to learn about what
happened we will keep you all updated
online and on air once we get more
details reporting live bianca holman
live local now